Hey listen if you're ever having a bad
day if you're ever feeling um really
undervalued or
useless I just want you to know that
you'll never feel less valued than the
rear view
mirror of the Lamborghini Heron stado
hear me out this is the off-road version
of this car it's got a ton of
modifications to it allterrain tires
it's lifted by 2 in a roof rack with a
spare tire with a run flat it's great
but part of being off-road means they've
moved the air intake higher off the
ground so if you drive through water or
mud or whatever there's a a roof scoop
here all of your air still goes in your
engine no matter what you're driving in
that means when you get in this
car behind you is the roof scoop the air
intake so why is why is this here why is
this not a camera it's just showing
me it's just showing me nothing this is
useless you'll never be this useless
you'll never be this useless